BILL LUAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So Chris, the first
question for you.
Since you have on your title
page that you mentioned,
now is the most exciting time.
Given that you're the vice
president, over charge a lot
of product development, you
also, on behalf of Google,
announced a lot of new features.
You had Google IO,
many other events.
In your personal view,
what do you think
are the most exciting
things for you
in terms of you looking at
all the past announcements,
features.
Among all those, what's the
most interesting to you?
CHRIS YERGA: Well, I think
new device categories
like Android Wear,
and Android TV,
and automotive are
certainly very interesting.
But actually, the thing
that excites me the most
is not necessarily the
flashy, new hardware products.
I'm excited about
much of the stuff
that Brahim just finished
talking about in terms
of expanding payments for Play.
Recently, we've done things like
launching new, direct carrier
billing integrations in the
Philippines and Thailand,
and launching gift cards in
places like Hong Kong or Korea.
And I think that
work that we focus
on tirelessly all the time, it's
not necessarily as glamorous
as some of the new
product launches.
But it's really exciting to
me, because with every new form
of payment we add in
a country, it benefits
all of the developers
on Google Play,
because we are a global market
having users in Southeast Asia,
or Russia, or new
places like that,
increases a number of
places that you can sell
your applications and games.
And that work is very important
and one that actually, I
get the most excited by.
BILL LUAN: Thank you, Chris.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Ellie, since you are the
product manager for Google Play
operations, there are a couple
of questions, very good,
in terms of the
features we have in Play
that enable the
developers interacting
with their customers.
So two of the questions, which
I think they interlink together.
One is whether we can consider,
allowing the developers to use
their control panel,
to have direct access
to their customers.
And number two, whether they
can even allow the control panel
to export their engagement
with the customer
so that they can do
more data analysis,
can do more follow up.
And my related question
to that is, in the past,
Google probably considered
that in the past,
if there's a reason
not to do so, and why.
So probably you're the best
person to elaborate on that.
So again, control panel using
that to engage with customers.
ELLIE POWERS: So I actually have
some good news for those of you
who have used the Google Play
Developer Console in the past.
Over time this
year, we've actually
been doing a lot
of work to make it
possible to export
all the different data
types from the Google
Play Developer Console.
So we had some
launches recently.
So you can actually export
your statistics, your crashes.
And you actually can export all
of your user reviews, as well.
If you go to
support.google.com, there's
basically a help article
that you can pull up
that gives you directions
on how to use this using
a utility that we
have called gsutil
so that again, allows you to
export all of your user reviews
using this utility.
And then you'll be able to do
whatever analysis that you want
to do with them after that.
It was something
that was recently
launched on Google Play.
So we're pretty
excited about it.
And just one quick tip for
everybody in the audience.
On the left hand side of the
Google Play Developer Console,
there is a little icon.
It looks like a megaphone.
And that's where
you can go to see
announcements of new features.
We also announced some
of our bigger features
on the Google Developer's
blog, as well.
Another common
question that we had
asked just now about how we're
replying to reviews works.
I'll give a little
bit more information,
because this is one of the most
common questions that we get.
So when a user leaves a review
on the Google Play Store,
the developer can respond
through the Google Play
Developer Console.
But what you may
not know actually
is what happens after that.
So we actually sent an email
notification to the user,
letting them know that the
developer has responded.
We provide the user with
the developer's email
address and let them know
that they can either contact
the developer directly
using that email address,
or by replying to
the mail, or they
can go and update their review
on Google Play if they want to.
So we don't disclose the
user's email addresses
to the developers, but we do
disclose the developer's email
addresses to the users.
So if users choose
to, they can engage
in a one on one conversation
with the developer.
But for privacy
reasons, we don't
share the individual
user's email addresses
with the developer.
So we think that
this is a good way
to balance privacy, as well as
a desire for direct interaction.
Some users do check their email.
They do receive these
emails, and they
do choose to reply to them.
Other users don't.
So I think you'll sometimes
find that some users will want
to talk with you one on
one, and others don't.
If you do you want users to
reach out to you directly,
when you reply to
their reviews, you
can mention that if they'd like
to have more of a conversation,
that this is their email
address that they can use,
or the website that
they can go to to get
more direct support from you.
BILL LUAN: Thank you.
The next speaker is Kevin.
So since Kevin's talking
about discoverability,
the question for you is do
you have further comments,
the discoverability of the
apps on Play changed over time
from your experience,
your observations?
Do you have any further
comment on that?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
KEVIN CHIAO: So I always
think about discoverability
as the holy grail of
the whole app ecosystem.
If you think about the most
important things we just all
covered today, I
always called it
the three R's, which is
reach, retention, and revenue.
Other than making
a great product,
you need to worry about
how do I get more users,
how do I keep them in my game,
and how do I make money off
of them?
If you think about what we
talked about this morning,
it's that whole story.
I talked about the reach.
Ellie talked about
the retention.
Brahim talked about the revenue.
How do we make more money?
And I used to be a
developer myself,
so I know how difficult
user acquisition can be.
And I think from
a lot of people,
because I started out
in the Apple ecosystem
doing a lot of user acquisition
there and trying to get
to the top of the charts.
And I realize every
day I would wake up,
and I would just
Apple R on my computer
and refresh the charts.
And I'm sure a
lot of you guys do
this where you wake up every--
you just refresh the charts.
You're like, where am I?
And you're like, I
just went from like 50
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
But it doesn't necessarily
correlate to more installs
or more revenue.
It's just an arbitrary
chart in a lot of ways
that people, for some reason,
they'll slave over it.
And they'll spend hundreds
and hundreds of thousands,
of millions of dollars to get
to the top of these charts.
And so over time, you've seen
discoverability change a lot
in the ecosystem, especially
because Google Play
has gotten a lot larger.
If you think about
two, three years ago,
Google Play's still very young.
And when it all started out--
I don't know if any of you guys
saw the videos earlier, but they
showed the Android marketplace,
the first UI.
And I don't know if
you guys remember that.
But I remember that
from a developer's side.
And I was like, why
would anyone develop
for this, because I was making
90% of my revenue on Apple.
But over time, that
has always changed.
And now, as Google
Play continues to grow,
as of revenue, the
retention, and we
bring all these great
resources for everyone here,
the discovery piece
means so much more.
But it's not just about
being on the top charts.
If you actually
look at the data,
search is the largest
for Google Play.
We are a search company,
so we should at least
get that part right.
So when it comes
to all of this, you
can sit there and spend
hundreds of thousands
of dollars on user
acquisition to try to get
to the top of the charts.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
This is like spam installs.
They use fake installs to
get to the top of the charts.
But it doesn't help
you in any way.
It might just get you to
the top of the charts.
But the things we
just talked about,
getting real users
into your game,
or getting real users
to discover your game,
getting them to retain, getting
them to make revenue-- this
won't happen just
off of top charts.
If you think about the
history of how all of this
has happened, what I really
want people to take away
is that everything we're
sharing with you today,
you get to the top of
the charts these days,
because you've done
everything right.
You've looked at your users.
You've built a strong community.
You go to regions.
You localize your listings.
You have very, very strong
community in that area.
And we'll talk more about that
today in a lot of the panels
that we'll be on.
And I really hope that we can
share more about that with you
guys further down the road.
BILL LUAN: Thank you Kevin.
[APPLAUSE]
They like your answer.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So a question for [INAUDIBLE]
about the different list
of four different
ads models that you
talked about this morning.
For a global market, due to the
differences in culture, custom,
behavior, and so on, from you
and your team's observations
from any past data,
where's anything
you could comment on
due to the culture
differences, the
custom behavior.
Which one of those models
will be most successful
that you would recommend
among our attendees
today if they want to go global
to help them to be successful?
Which one should
to be used first?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALE SPEAKER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
[APPLAUSE]
BILL LUAN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
That's like a food chain.
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
So Bryan, you talked about
monetize opportunities
on Play this morning.
And since a lot of
topics we covered
are so far, including
doing the Q&A,
all the other speakers
are talking about things
that you should do to help
you be more successful.
However, the question
about monetizing,
one of the good questions
raised is actually the reverse.
What are the things that you
should not do which if you do,
will prevent you to
be less successful,
or prevent you to be more
successful, causing you to be
less successful in monetizing?
The second question
is rather frank
and a straightforward,
tough question--
why does Google Payments
sometimes seem so slow?
And I believe you have
a good answer for that.
So these questions, on to you.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Thank you.
So we've talked a lot
about what you should do,
and that is great.
But I think obviously,
all of those inverse
are things you shouldn't do.
But a couple of tactical
items that we hear a lot about
is, for example, there are a lot
of boilerplate implementations
of our in-app billing APIs.
And lots of developers would
actually take that and just
drop it in their app as a
standard implementation.
And what ends up
happening is a lot
of users actually
make purchases.
And they don't receive the
item they just purchased,
for some reason or the other.
This is our number one
driver for support tickets.
And actually, it just creates
such a bad experience,
because someone just
literally decided
to spend their money with you.
And they didn't get that
good they just purchased.
And a lot of times,
they find this
is because of these kind
of copy/paste errors
where there are some
implementations out there.
They aren't good, and
so they get dropped,
and they get reiterated,
implemented over, and over,
and over.
And so it's somewhat
a simple fix,
because implementation's
actually
pretty straightforward.
But this causes lots of your
users to have a bad experience
and then request
refunds, et cetera.
So this is a tactical thing
that I would love for everyone
to just go look and
implement right,
especially as you all are
embarking in that journey now.
The second point which
I've heard a lot about
is around game mechanics, and
how or even app mechanics.
How do you build an
experience that's
welcoming, so that
the user actually
gets enough of an
experience that they're
willing to then spend?
Too often, we hear immediately,
a lot of developers
build apps that immediately
try to monetize the user.
Maybe they get
through one level,
and then they start
hitting those roadblocks.
And you can see this in the
reviews for these apps, where
users will say,
monetizing aggressively,
or can't really play, or need
to spend way too much money
to progress.
And this is a matter of
patience and actually
building an app that welcomes
the user, actually gives them
a really great
immersive experience,
and then try to monetize it.
So that's a fundamental way
of building your app possibly.
But it could make a
significant difference
in your monetization.
So those two tactical,
slash long term things
I would like to talk about.
I'm assuming there are
two aspects too slow.
I'm not sure which one
we're talking about.
One is literally latency
of the purchase experience.
And over the past year, actually
about a year or plus ago,
we launched an entirely
new implementation
for our purchase flow, which
had three things in mind.
One is simplicity.
Two is keeping the user in
context of your application,
and three was latency.
And we actually cut latency
at the time by over 40%,
and in some markets here
in Asia, by more than that.
So latency, very
technically, is something
that we are obsessed about.
We know that it is
not perfect yet,
but we have teams that are
working on making that better.
The other part of slow
that I wasn't sure about
is launching, new
forms of payment,
and expanding our reach.
And that aspect
goes back to what
I mentioned earlier
about payments
being one of the key value-adds
that we delivere to you,
in addition to distribution.
Payments are really difficult.
I've worked on it
for three years.
We have large teams of people
that are working specifically
on this problem.
It is just difficult.
For example, when you launch
a payment service in Brazil,
you need to have 24/7
support in Portuguese.
So setting up those sorts of
operations in brand new markets
is incredibly difficult.
Of course, going to the
regulatory and licensing
aspects is difficult.
Of course, I'm not
trying to find excuses.
But payments are difficult.
This is what we believe,
that Google Play offers you
a great platform for reaching
buyers in 130 markets plus,
and you're not having
to worry about that.
So that, in a way,
is our value add.
But we do realize that
we can move faster,
and we are, to use the term,
doubling down on payments
and making sure that we can
move even faster over the coming
year or so.
I don't want to do whichever it
was, but those are the answers.
Thank you.
BILL LUAN: Thank you, Brahim.
[APPLAUSE]
So due to time
limitations we're going
to end our Q&A, because it's
about time for everybody
to have lunch.
So please put your
hands together,
thanking all of our
speakers for their answers.
Thank you to all our speakers.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]